jour de fête pour le village d'enfants
sos de plaisir un anniversaire célébré
avec tous les acteurs de cette
association présente notamment marie
claude engagé depuis cinq ans au sos
villages d'enfants elle s'occupe
actuellement de deux fratries et deux
autres enfants
quatre adolescentes de 14 à 18 ans deux
garçons de 9 et 10 ans on organise des
jeux on part en vacances ensemble
il ya beaucoup d'humour aussi sur la
maison c'est des enfants qui sont
remplis d'humour d'imagination et c'est
vrai qu'on s'amuse bien comme une maman
je m'occupe de tout ce qui concerne leur
bien-être la scolarité les soins les
loisirs comme une maman la cause des
enfants c'est une cause qui me tient à
coeur
j'ai tout temps enfin l'enfant de
maintenance et l'adulte de demain
c'est peut-être aussi un côté politique
âgé de 20 ans julie bila est arrivé en
novembre 2005 avec ses cinq frères et
soeurs pendant les vacances scolaires on
allait souvent dans la famille même de
notre éducatrice familiale donc ça nous
a permis de faire partie de la famille
d'ailleurs on les appelle tout ce papy
et mamie à tâtons tout ça m'a permis de
mieux grandir je pense que dans le cadre
de ma famille ça m'a permis de resserrer
les liens fraternels fraternelle mes
frères et soeurs et on a un lien très
soudée le village d'enfants sos de
plaisir est situé dans le quartier de
l'aqueduc
quinze maisons disent occupés par des
familles 54 enfants sont accueillis
la mission de l'association conserver le
lien entre frères et soeurs pour les
enfants placés dans le cadre juridique
de la protection de l'enfance de tout
enfant quel qu'il soit quel que soit sa
situation
s'il a des frères et soeurs
ses frères et soeurs viennent là dans
l'histoire familiale et nous nous
privilégions cela ça nous permet de
déconstruire en quelque sorte cette
histoire là pour mieux reconstruire
l'avenir en france près de 1000 enfants
vivent dans les 14 villages d'enfants
sos cette ong présentes dans 134 pays
dans le monde